refugee worker Muhammed Yasha has packed
some pita bread a few tomatoes and soda
for the children he knows it's barely
enough for one meal for the seven-member
family he's about to visit three years
ago the azim EES fled to Turkey from
Afghanistan they'd planned to have
arrived in Europe a long time ago but
instead they're stuck here on the
outskirts of Istanbul for weeks now
they've been afraid to leave the house
mount a fear of the coronavirus or of
getting deported they only let you
shower into their flat he takes their
temperature and gives them food ration
cards they're worried about getting sick
without health insurance and they feel
unwanted in Turkey refugees are being
evicted even if they've paid the rent
Raisa the family's eldest son is
appearing on the social media channel of
Mohammed's relief organization he's
recounting their experiences in recent
weeks
you already know what happened to us at
the Greek border how hard it was for his
there
the Azimi is arrived at the Greek border
at the end of February along with tens
of thousands of other refugees the
Turkish government have just announced
that the doors were open for them to go
to Europe but on the other side of the
fence Greece had slammed the door to the
EU shut several attempts to cross the
border by force were beaten down
each other called kinesin 2% everyday
they told us we'd be off today or
tomorrow if you who made it to the Greek
side were violently driven back into
Turkey like these Iranians who were even
stripped of their clothes
for a month razor Azimi and others
waited at the border in the freezing
cold and filth then one night the
Turkish police showed up they dragged us
out of our tents with force
then they set her belongings on fire
pushed us onto buses and drove us off we
were on the road for 20 hours we only
had dried bread to eat we weren't
allowed to disembark the family was
brought to Malatya 1,400 kilometers away
they were put in a quarantine facility
like this a few days later they were
taken to a place near Ankara ultimately
all the refugees of the Greek border
ended up on the streets somewhere in
Turkey so did the Azimi family the
people around the world they say have
lost any interest in their fate we've
been taken advantage of as a political
football everyone knows that by now
not just the refugees at the whole
international community at the end of
their Odyssey the volunteer refugee
worker Mohammed Yasha got them off the
street and into a two-room flat the
azumi's share it with another refugee
family but it's unclear if they'll be
able to stay there's the coronavirus too
and the way to europe is blocked and we
can't work either our life is hopeless
when I ask for work they say we don't
take foreigners the Izumi's dream of a
life in Europe has become a nightmare
raises father says turkey doesn't want
them but they can't go back to
Afghanistan either captain normal
religion Gibbs / give somebody choice
and we should return we left our home
for the sake of our children now they
aren't even able to go to school and so
they do what they can to get by with
just some bread tomatoes and a few
olives their only option is to wait and
hope hope that turkey accepts them or
Europe opens her arms